would you recommend to other creators
that wanna that wanna make it big to and
they see Mr Beast and they look up to
you to copy some elements of you or to
really try to be unique unique 100
unique you're not the next Mr Beast
going quotes because we're saying that
third person but whatever is not gonna
do what I'm doing better they're gonna
invent their own lane like you're just
not gonna do what I do better than me
you know I have so many I literally have
the best people in the world working
here and I reinvest everything I make
even to this day you know what I mean
like it's absurd the amount of money is
spent on content and I don't care I'll
just stop sleeping and I'll just film
every other day like you're just not
gonna beat me at my own game and that's
fine you shouldn't like I didn't get
where I am by just beating someone else
in their own game I just found my own
lane and innovated and adapted and so
yeah there's a lot of people that do
copy me and it's fine whatever do it but
just know you're not gonna get to where
I am doing that
um and so I'd advise you don't you give
away a lot of the secrets basically
everything yeah about how you operate is
there uh I don't hold anything back go
for it you know how do you think about
that because that's also that's pretty
rare I think and this is a definitely
not uh most people in my stance I don't
think would take this or my position
would take this stance but I see every
other YouTuber or so person on social
media even because we're also focused
super heavily on YouTube but last year
we're also the most followed Tick Tock
Creator in the world as well I actually
remember most subscribed to YouTube
channel world and the most followed Tick
Tock account in the world
um but uh in general I just see everyone
else as uh collaborators not competitors
I I don't
think giving advice and helping other
creators do well in any way harms me and
I think it only brings more value to my
life